Film Courage What do you think can be helpful
for screenwriters when they look at the science
behind writing and story?
Dr. Connie Shears, Professor Crean at Chapman
University and Author: I think it’s profoundly
helpful for a screenwriter to recognize the
physiological processes that their audiences
are experiencing.
To have at least a minimal understanding of
the visual and the auditory information is
being received the same by everybody’s eyes
and ears work the same way but once that information
is transduced into neural impulses in the
brain that is where the screenwriter needs
to understand that every person in there is
working from a different schema, an organized
set of their experiences, building up their
own individual expectations.
Here is where the screenwriter can capitalize
on general experiences.
So in this day and age almost everybody has
seen a movie or has watched video clips so
there’s a certain amount of experience that
exists at a general level.
What can they do in their screenwriting to
make that unique, to make that individual,
to make their story stand out from the expected.
I think understanding the inner weaving of
memory and language and emotion with the psychical
processes of what the audience is seeing or
hearing is key to the way we dedicate our
book to the success of future storytellers.
I think storytelling will take on really fascinating
new perspectives when screenwriters begin
to consider the brain processes of the audience
that they are telling the story to.